Speaker 1: I want to start today by talking
generally about political violence in the
United States. What I mean by this is acts
of real world violence that are politically
motivated or politically oriented. And of course,
the context is this horrifying attack by a right
wing anti-vaccine, anti-Semitic. Q And on not on
Nancy Pelosi's husband, Paul Pelosi, which we will
get to. But one of the things that the right has
been doing in response to this horrible attack,
that this obviously politically motivated attack
is a lot of both sides. Well, we generically
condemn violence, and violence is bad no matter
who does it. Violence in general is unacceptable.
But let's not pretend that it is the same on both
sides. First of all, they aren't actually telling
the truth that they see left and right wing
violence in the same way. Their reaction to
the January, January 6th Trump riots, excuse me,
is great evidence of that. But more importantly,
they are looking to say, well, just violence
is bad, but overwhelmingly the violence comes
from their side. There is a very good study
from the New America think tank which found
that most political violence is right wing. And in
fact, they have number of people killed in deadly
attacks in the post-9-11 era. This is four deaths.
And then we have other incidents of violence where
nobody does. Number of people killed by ideology.
And you will see that there is 122 which are far
right wing and 107 that are jihadist. 17
are ideological misogynists slash incels,
which is another right wing reactionary ideology.
Then you've got your black separatist nationalist
supremacist and one that is far left wing.
Other than the one far left wing. These are
all essentially right wing ideologies now, you
might say. But, David, the jihadists, folks,
jihadists are right wing. Tell me what left wing
views jihadist Muslims have. They have the exact
same views as the far right Christians, except
under the guise of Islam rather than Christianity.
So overwhelmingly, right wing violence is
the cause of a death in the United States
in politically violent acts. There is
another study called A Comparison of
Political Violence by Left Wing, right wing and
Islamic Islamist extremists in the United States
and the world. And what this study finds, and
we'll link to it and you can read through it,
is that most political violence, both
domestically in the United States and globally,
is carried out by right wing ideology, by
right wingers. Now there is another layer.
It isn't just the right wing that is perpetrating
most of the political violence. It's also that the
left wing is mostly the victim of that violence
as well. You can have right wingers generically
committing acts of violence, and the victims are
a random assortment of those based on political
ideology. But no, it is left wingers that are
overwhelmingly the victims of this right wing
violence as well. And if you think we can count on
the right to help reduce such violence, forget it.
Think back to the start of the pandemic. They
couldn't even pitch in and just wear masks or
get themselves vaccinated for the greater
good. There is no way that they would pitch
in to work together to make sure society doesn't
collapse well under the weight of this violence,
given that they are overwhelmingly the ones
perpetrating that violence. They hate higher
education. They say that's liberal indoctrination.
They say that medicine is increasingly biased,
left wingers giving their social opinions when it
comes to vaccines and all these other guidelines
related to the pandemic on all of these different
things. They are willing to let the world,
the country, burn for their ideology. It doesn't
matter. Science doesn't matter, empiricism doesn't
matter, reality doesn't matter to them. The other
aspect to this that is important to consider
is that when you look at stochastic
terrorism, meaning the vague calls to violence
issued to their respective audiences, you just
don't see that on the left. Now I know you can
find isolated examples of some Black Lives
Matter or Antifa activists with no following,
other than 1500 people on Twitter saying Down
with their heads or something like that. But
what I'm talking about is Tucker Carlson, Alex
Jones, Steve Bannon, Trump himself at rallies,
the leaders of their movement, prominent
people saying, we got to knock them around,
knock the hell out of them, I'll pay for the
legal fees, all of these different things.
They are causing this to a great degree. And so
the both sides ism has to stop. And by the way,
the more we learn about the Paul Pelosi attack,
the more we know that it was simply a right wing
nut targeting Nancy Pelosi because he doesn't like
her political views. Let's talk about that next.